[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
outsiders
i paid my dues
time after time
i've done my sentence
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've made a few
[Music]
we are the champions
my friends
[Applause]
[Music]
we are the champions
of the world
[Music]
i thank you all but it's
been no bed of rosie
[Music]
no pleasure crew
i consider it a challenge
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
and now the end is near
and so i face
the final curtain
my friend i'll say it clear
i'll state my case
of which i'm certain
i've lived a life
that's full i traveled
each and every highway
and more much more than this
i did it my
[Music]
way regrets
i've had a few
but then again
too few to mention
i did what i
had to do
saw it through without
exemption i planned
[Music]
each charted course each careful step
[Music]
along the byway
and more much more than this
i did it my
way yes there were times
i'm sure you knew
when i fit off more than i could choose
but through it all
[Music]
stood tall and did it my way
i've had my fill
my share of losing
and now as tears subside
i find it all so
amusing to think
i did all that
[Music]
and may i say
not in a shy way
[Music]
oh no oh no
not me i did it
for what is a man
what has he got
if not himself
then he has not to say
the things he truly feels
[Music]
my way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hold on hold
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
i know where you've been
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's the first time
the last time
[Music]
me
[Music]
well
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
rising up back on the street
[Music]
so many times it happens too fast
you change your passion for glory
don't lose your grip on the dreams of
the past
you must fight just to keep them alive
[Music]
face the face
[Music]
is
of the tigers
[Music]
now i'm not gonna stop
[Music]
those survivors
[Music]
[Music]
the dagger
i'm tired
[Music]
i hope
[Music]
body
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
muscles
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
on my body
[Music]
oh
[Music]
every night
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
somehow
[Music]
so careful not to show
[Music]
all the voices in your head
[Music]
don't you think
[Music]
calling foreign
[Music]
i think they got the
[Music]
but you aliens don't remember
[Music]
don't
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
don't believe
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president of the united states
donald j trump
who gave and i gladly stand up
next to you and defend her still today
but there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from detroit down to houston
and new york to valencia
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
who died who gave that life to me
and i gladly stand up next to you
and defend her still today
i love this land
[Music]
god bless
[Music]
[Music]
i know i'm free
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
and i'm bout to be an american
where at least i
[Music]
today
[Applause]
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit town to houston
and new york to l.a
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
that i'm proud to be an american
where at least i
[Music]
[Music]
and defend her still today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
god
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave
[Music]
god
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a lot of people thank you very
[Applause]
much
wow thank you very much
and hello goodyear hello phoenix
six days can you believe the six days
from now
we are going to win arizona and we are
going to win
four more years in our great
beautiful white house
a vote for me is a vote for massive
tax cuts regulation cuts
fair trade strong borders our second
amendment we will save our second
amendment
and american energy independence
it's a vote to support our police
our military stand up to china
which we've been doing they gave 28
billion dollars to our farmers that's
very nice thank you very much
and it's your more products that are
proudly stamped with that beautiful
phrase
made in the usa
[Applause]
we will deliver record prosperity epic
job growth and a safe vaccine that
eradicates the virus the china plague is
what it is
and quickly ends the pandemic
normal life which is what we want we
just want normal life
like we had seven months ago
we'll fully resume and next year we will
be the greatest economic
power we are going to be stronger than
we've ever been before and you see that
all happening
next year will be the best economic year
in our country's history and last year
was
and then we were interrupted we were
interrupted
let's go make america great again again
a vote for joe biden sleepy joe
is a vote for the biggest tax hike in
history i've never seen this before
amanda's campaigning on the fact that
he's gonna raise your taxes i haven't
said
they're going to crush regulations it
will be crushing you have no idea what
they want to do we took off
more regulations than any administration
in the history of our country they are
going to put
those regulations back and all they do
is cause waste
and a lot of other problems slash
medicare and social security
and they want to abolish american energy
you know what he said no fracking he
said no fracking
until he went to pennsylvania then he
said maybe we can frack
his people won't let him frack and joe
doesn't have any clue where he is you
know that
where am i where am i what state am i in
he's only got it wrong about seven times
where am i is this arizona or is this
nevada where am i
tell me where am i is this iowa oh oh oh
oh it's very hot
i know where i am this is florida isn't
it
no joe no joe
a vote for biden is a vote for open
borders
offshoring jobs shredding the second
amendment
confiscating your guns and eliminating
private healthcare 180 million people on
private healthcare
it's called bye and they love their
private healthcare
biden and the democrat socialists will
delay the vaccine prolong the pandemic
shutter your schools and shut down our
country
and your state is open right your state
is nice and open
your state is nice and open thank you
the governor did a good job i don't know
if you appreciate it but he did a good
job
you had a spike and he just sort of did
what he had to do and your state is
fully open
good job he may be here he may be in
this crowd of about 25
000 people he may be here i
may get lucky and introduce him a little
bit he is here he's a great governor
this election is a choice between the
american dream and a socialist nightmare
as long as i am president america will
never
ever be a socialist country
[Applause]
i am fighting for the dreams of all
americans including millions of truly
amazing and they like me my poll numbers
are through the roof with
hispanic americans right through
you i always knew they liked me
it's a big story they say what's going
on i just thought what's going on with
trump
and the hispanics what's going on with
trump
his poll numbers they're getting very
nervous you know our poll numbers are
looking very good
we had one little upset this morning
we're doing very well in wisconsin
i was there yesterday we had 25 000
people at least
i will tell you it was cold i made one
yesterday i did three of these yesterday
don't make me cry don't make me cry
they'll say the president was crying
i don't know i don't know if i want a
president of the cries but it's okay
but you know that's the phrase one of
the greatest men in the
country right here did you ever hear did
you ever hear that phrase before i don't
think so oh we have mike lee here too
and we have rand paul here and sergio
and the king of europe we have right
here
rand did you ever hear that phrase for a
politician
rand would like that phrase i can tell
you right now
[Applause]
so so we got some great polls and we are
getting great polls we're doing great in
florida
doing great at north carolina doing
great i think in pennsylvania i think
i think it's going to be great we want
it last time first time in many years
republican won we've done good brought a
lot of business there
did a lot of business went back to
pennsylvania so i think they appreciate
it but haven't seen the numbers they
vote late you know they vote like on
tuesday that's what they like i like
that too
but we're doing good all over we're
doing good in wisconsin we have a poll
we're one up in wisconsin don't don't
clap yet
today the fake washington post
abc now you know you think they've come
out that he's four down he's five down
17 down and wisconsin
i had the same fraudsters here four
years ago they had me 12 down a week
before the election right
remember that i was 12 down abc
washington post bad
i mean just dishonest people
and we sent them a legal letter and by
the time we got to the
election we were like even i wonder what
happened
but you know they interviewed slightly
more democrats than republicans we
looked at it i think there's some kind
of a law that you have to do that
they interviewed a few more like a
number that you wouldn't even believe
i agree
i agree i agree but they're all sort of
in that bag they're all you know
abc terrible nbc is probably the worst
of all it's called comcast c-o-n.com
c-o-n comcast because they're cons it's
a big con job
it's a big con job you know they spend
all that money for public relations and
then i talk about them that's the end of
the public relations
con job how did you guys do today please
on section 230
mike lee how are you doing section you
know what what they're doing is a
disgrace
joe biden is a corrupt politician and
they refuse to talk about it
you got to do it you got to do it i mean
it's crazy they're getting away
what the big tech is getting away with
they will not allow
anybody to even discuss it with me they
write false
stories they can do whatever they want
section 230 rand i hope you're all
looking at it okay
i hope you're all looking at it
because it was a lot of stuff today you
know they were up there and they were
very nervous in front of the senate
they were very nervous i have to tell
you that they were shaken up a little
bit
because without section 230 they don't
even exist
they don't even exist for 47 years joe
biden betrayed the american people
and he betrayed hispanic americans
over the last four years i've been
delivering for hispanic americans like
never before
[Music]
and hispanic american unemployment
reached
an all-time low prior to the
pandemic
it's crazy i love you too
nobody knows what happened the fake news
they're going look at all of them back
there
that's a lot of that's a lot of fake
news back there
look at that those red lights just went
off you know anytime i refer to them
they turn the light off
very quickly they don't want to have it
broadcast what i call
cnn bad names
hispanic american families saw their net
worth skyrocket by
64 percent
[Applause]
and i'm sitting in the hottest sun i've
ever felt
[Applause]
this is hot my last stop also
in your great state it had a different
problem the sun was hot
i've never seen wind like that
it's lucky i don't need teleprompters
like sleepy joe
because the teleprompters were falling
down they were going all over the place
i was getting a headache i'm trying to
look
but i have a good memory i remember
things
unlike unlike the sleepy one you know
he's in a lit again do you know that
fellas he's gonna live he gets
this guy's in a lid every single day
that refers to a garbage can they put
the lid on the can
he's in his he's in his basement you
know
by the way i'd like to be in a basement
i'd like to be in some place i'd like to
be in a beautiful bedroom
nice for a year and a half two years
never come out to whiteout
but i'm your president i have to i have
to come out i have to meet people
we have to meet people
and i said you know this could be a
little bit shaky right to meet
a lot of people but we have no choice
and
you probably haven't heard but i caught
it i caught it did anybody know that i
caught it
and then you get better and you're
immune and they say you're immune for a
year
they used to say you're immune forever
but when i got it i said i'm immune they
said it's only for four months i don't
know what happened
they said you're immune for a lifetime
right remember until i had it once i had
it now it's only up to four but
but i got better great doctors at the
white house we have great doctors great
doctors all over the country
i had doctors from all over the country
you know one thing i learned quickly
when you're the president and you're not
feeling too good i did feel great
you have more doctors than you've ever
seen in your life before i was like
it was like a public place and they were
gathered around my bed they said what's
the problem i said i don't know
doc but i'm not feeling too good and i
gotta get back on the trail you know
what the trail is
right the campaign trail i gotta get
back on the trail
get me the hell out of here doc johns
hopkins was great we have all the great
hospitals represented
and i'll tell you walter reed is
incredible i've seen what they do to
soldiers they come back so badly wounded
they fix him thank you thank you
walter reed is so great but they're all
around and they're saying sir
i think uh you're gonna have to take it
easy for a little while and they gave me
something called regeneron you ever hear
of regenero
and we're gonna make it available to
everybody that needs it
free free right free
antibodies and all i know and i don't
want to give any credit to this drug i
want to say it was me because i'm in
perfect physical condition and i'm very
young
i'm very young and i'm in perfect
physical shape
perfect
[Music]
you know i said that jokingly i said
that
a couple of weeks ago cnn fake news here
then went crazy
he's not in perfect shape but he's not
young
they went crazy they thought it was
horrible a horrible
horrible statement now we we did a great
job and i would like to say that the
antibody that what they gave me didn't
know but it probably did
because i woke up the next morning and i
felt like superman i wanted to
i wanted to rip my shirt off just like
clockhead
anybody ever hear clockhead just like
the legendary clockhead
[Applause]
you know we're gonna win the election
you know that i'm gonna win this is not
this is much more so than four years ago
i'm looking at some of our great
senators we're gonna win this election
we're going to have a great victory and
a lot of people want to go out on
tuesday they don't want to go out early
it's called
the great red wave way music
they always say sir could you please ask
them to go out on monday sunday you know
because you can go out now you can vote
right
but i said they don't really want that
they want to go out you know they want
to make it a little more convenient for
you
but when those booths open up you're
going to see something that probably has
never seen before you've never seen
in florida they're not doing well they
had to get that lead
that lead's going to be taken over i
think very very quickly
the biggest problem we have is if they
cheat with the ballots that's my biggest
problem that's the only thing
that's the only thing i worry about if
they cheat with the ballots right
if they cheat with the ballots and you
know they did find some in a garbage can
from the military military ballots had
the name trump written they wanted to go
for trump
they found him in a garbage can now if
they ch
oh hundreds of thousands every day you
don't wake up and not read a story about
it every day there's cheating with the
ballots
and you have governors democrat
governors that are players
wise guys wise guys and uh
it's a disgrace you know in nevada we
like
nevada but you got a governor there
that's a player
and even if you want to speak they make
it very hard
to find a location but we found one and
50
000 people showed up a couple of weeks
ago
latino homeownership is now at an
all-time high
all-time high
and by the way if you look at new houses
if you look at automobile production
it's hard to believe it literally is
superseding what we had
prior to the pandemic and nobody's even
imagining that
to bring even greater opportunity and
prosperity to latino
and latino community and i say the
latinos and i say the hispanics and have
a lot of friends i say what do you like
better they said
you can call us anything
[Applause]
the latino community in arizona and
around the country today i'm announcing
the american dream plan
over the next four years the american
dream plan will bring more than two
million new jobs
to hispanic communities create over a
half a million new
hispanic small businesses
which will end up being large businesses
if i know you and i know you well
great business people great natural
business people
expand opportunities for federal
contracting it's going to be much easier
for you to get
some of those jobs and increase access
to capital
by hundreds of billions of dollars
you're going to be in great shape you're
going to say i liked him very much
now if sleepy joe gets said they're
going to ask him about it he's not going
to have a clue he's not going to be able
to tell you this
more hispanic americans will be able to
buy a home
to afford quality health insurance and
to raise their families in a beautiful
safe neighborhood
and i will provide school choice to
every parent in america
school choice
joe biden would obliterate everything
hispanic americans have worked for
wiping out your small businesses with
lockdowns and regulations
gutting your police departments and
devastating your families with massive
tax hikes he will attack catholic
organizations by the way hispanics
generally speaking don't like that too
much and
ban charter schools fund extreme late
term abortion
and surrender your country to the
violent
socialist mob and you see that happening
how about portland right
you know how quick we could fix that
mike lee we could fix that in about what
30 minutes right the governor has to
call up he said
maybe a little bit less that's why we're
going to win
a record share of the hispanic vote this
election day
we are going to win a number that's
never been won by a republican and maybe
maybe we're going to beat the democrats
that will be incredible that will be
that means you're on your way to great
business in 2016
arizona voted to fire our failed and
corrupt
political establishment and you elected
an outsider as
president who is finally putting america
first
taking a long time
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician
and if i don't always play by the rules
of the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you harder than any president
has ever fought for their constituents
before to show you
how corrupt the washington media is
i was just and did you see this this was
just revealed
it was just revealed that you know
anonymous you know this
anonymous that everybody's been looking
for that law enforcement could have
found early if they wanted to
but everybody was looking for anonymous
turned out to be a low-level staffer
a sleazebag who's never worked in the
white house
anonymous was a nobody a disgruntled
employee who was quickly removed from
his job a long time ago for
they tell me incompetence i don't know
what for but they tell me incompetence
you know where he works now she wants to
cnn can you believe it
works at cnn he wrote a phony book
it was just basically if you read if you
heard about anonymous was like somebody
that was right next to me
i thought it might have been hope hicks
was right
i thought it might have been jared i
thought it might have been
mike lee i was worried from the great
state of utah
i was extremely worried about rand paul
maybe it was rand
this is a low level low life
that i don't know i have no idea who he
is other than i got to see him a little
while ago on television
and i think they threw him out a long
time ago his phony book was just based
on
fake articles and left-wing outlets
he worked with the listen to this
the fake news new york times right
[Music]
and he's an employee of google he works
for google isn't that nice
the people that you guys are looking at
right now the whole thing was just one
more
giant hoax from the washington swamp and
a corrupt
special interest group i'll tell you
what
this guy in my opinion he should be
prosecuted
he should be prosecuted
the left-wing media and the swamp are
doing everything in their power to try
and stop us
and by the way we're here and they're
not
and their heads are exploding their
heads are exploding
the media has been peddling their lives
for the last four years
and they've had a lot to say but in the
meantime
here we are and we're going to win the
greatest election and you know what
this election is more important than
any election in the history of our
country
including the last one and i never
thought i'd say that
but you get the last word on november
3rd
you can ensure that when the results
pour in
the corrupt media oh they're going to
have are you guys ready for this look at
all of them
look at all of those corrupt people
[Music]
look at all of those corrupt people the
corrupt media i used to call them the
fake news i thought it was one of the
great terms i made but it's not strong
enough
the corrupt media is bowing their heads
in shame
not cheering for sleepy
i can't imagine why they want them i
mean i can't figure it that one i can't
figure
but it's up to you this is your country
and you have to save and create a great
beautiful pathway for your country
get out and vote
you're going to show up in record
numbers vote for america
and against the corrupt media and
against the swamp
and nobody ever told me the swamp was
that deep
or that vicious swamp creatures they are
there
and some of the worst creatures in the
swamp are the rhinos we got some rhinos
but they are a dying breed they are a
dying breed they're getting a little
tired
they're getting a little tired of
calling it wrong it's incredible
under biden's cruel and senseless slot
downs
countless americans will die from
suicide
drug overdose deferred medical care
alcoholism abuse so many different
things
the cure cannot be worse than the
problem itself
we would say that we talk about that
rant right brand knows
that's what happens what happens to
a society what happens to a country you
take a look at michigan where she has
everybody locked down we won a case
in the supreme court michigan the
constitutionality we wanted they said it
was unconstitutional but in the meantime
she goes on with the appeals
the only one that's free to roam in
michigan is her husband
he's the only one he's allowed to go
boating and do whatever he wants
we gotta open up pennsylvania we gotta
open up north carolina
gotta open up california gotta open up
new york
if i lived in california new york
illinois i'd vote for trump
[Applause]
and you know what i used to say and it's
come so well our relationship
because of criminal justice reform and
prison reform and all the other things
with the african-american community
i used to say what the hell do you have
to lose and they agreed with me and
we're doing incredible the relationship
what we've done is incredible what we've
done is incredible but i say the same
thing that the people living in new york
california illinois automatic wins for
the democrats
i say vote for trump we'll cut your
taxes we'll get you back
we'll bring it back i say what the hell
do you have to lose
vote for trump there's three big stakes
you know it's tough when you have those
three big states automatically it's like
automatically put into it doesn't matter
who runs no matter who if we brought
back the
late great abraham lincoln new york
california illinois
so we got to run the gauntlet we got to
run the coast right
we and that's what happened last time we
won florida
and we won south carolina we won georgia
we won north carolina remember that was
going to be their firewall
that didn't work out too well for them
and we won pennsylvania
[Music]
and we just ran the coast didn't was
that a beautiful was that
that was one of the most exciting
evenings mike lee right
mike lee utah and we won utah right we
won them all
we won them all we had they said there
is no way to 270 remember 270 you need
270.
there is no way for donald trump this
was at five o'clock before the polls
lost
there is no way for donald trump to get
to 270.
like we're wasting our time i said i
don't think so but they turned out to be
right we couldn't get to 270 but we did
get to 306.
right there is no way
remember that one ohio ohio is great won
by eight points
they thought we're gonna tie they
thought it was going to be close you're
not close
and they called immediately donald trump
has won the state of ohio
and then they said not only one he's won
by eight points they said that is that
that was the beginning they said what's
going on here we're going to have a
bigger surprise
in six days there
[Applause]
[Music]
if you vote for biden it means no kids
in school
no graduations no weddings no
thanksgiving
no christmas and no 4th of july
together other than that you have a
wonderful life
can't see anybody but that's all right
you have a wonderful life
he wants everyone to and it's not really
again it's not him i'm using this thing
but it's
[Music]
he's a puppet he's a beauty i'll tell
you
look look look i shouldn't say this
because it's very disrespectful but i
don't care
because he's not a nice
we have some historians here true
american historians here
he is the worst candidate ever to run
in the history of a preacher if a
presidential election yes
the worst that's why there's tremendous
pressure on me
i wish he was a good candidate at least
if you lost you could say hey you lost
to a good candidate
how the hell do you lose to a guy like
this
i don't care i don't care we're going to
win we got to win
you're going to lose your country if you
don't win
the worst in presidential politics
now you're going to lose your country
it'll be a disaster he's not going to be
running things you have
kamala kamala
you know if you don't pronounce her name
exactly right she gets very angry at you
and then she starts you know what she
does when she gets angry she starts
laughing
like she did in 16 minutes
uncontrollable laughs
that means she's angry
sleepy joe wants to keep everyone locked
down forever including young people
which will cause enormous harm to
hispanic americans african-americans
asian-americans women men everybody
the biden plan will crush you and your
family
my plan will crush the virus and make
our strong
we're going to be stronger stronger than
ever before
our country will be stronger than ever
before
biden is the candidate of layoffs
lockdowns and
misery i am the candidate of jobs
vaccines and prosperity
our early and aggressive actions saved
over 2 million american lives
we saw we had to make a decision
we closed it up we understood it we
saved remember we're supposed to be 2.2
million people were going to die
we started doing ventilators we didn't
have ventilators
we became the king of ventilators all
over the world we're now sending
ventilators
all over the world we did a great job we
weren't acknowledged we have
governors saying what a great job we did
everybody was saying what a great job
we did a great job wasn't acknowledged
and that's okay
but the generals the admirals mike pence
all of these people that worked on this
they should be acknowledged we did a job
the likes of which
nobody thought remember joe biden with
the
h1n1 which he always reverses
h1n1 right he goes n1h1 i said no jokes
the swine flu right it's the swine flu
he was a disaster his chief of staff
said they didn't know what the hell they
were doing
and now he's always telling me i should
have acted quicker except when i closed
our country
to china because it was so heavily
affected and europe
he was totally against it he said it's
he said
um xenophobic i said do me a favor
give me a definition joe he couldn't do
that because he didn't
he had no idea but here are some of the
governors talking about what a great job
we've all done we've done
but what a great job we've done in
fighting the china virus
every time i called the president he's
quickly gotten on the line
when we asked to get support for that
mercy ship in southern california he was
able to direct that in real time
what the federal government did working
with states
was a phenomenal accomplishment uh we
got 2 000
of these vehicle field medical sites uh
that are up
almost all operational now in the state
because of his support
those are the facts uh his team has been
on it
i know a team when they're on it i know
a team when they're not on it
his team is on it they've been
responsive late at night
early in the morning we are working very
well with fema region 2 and with the
army corps of engineers
building four field hospitals that was a
decision the president himself took and
i'm grateful for it
these were just extraordinary efforts
and
acts of mobilization and
uh the federal government stepped up uh
we needed help and they were there
he said everything uh that i could have
hoped
for uh and we had a very long
conversation
and every single thing he said they
followed through on
we've got to have double the number of
ventilators that we requested for that
area of the state and in fact
we got them in frankly short order have
we lost anyone
because we didn't have a bed or we
didn't have a ventilator
or we didn't have health care staff
no the president was extending support
for new
swabs so conversation commitment
uh promise made promise kept
now to be fair maybe biden's not telling
us
because he's forgotten his own plans
watch biden's staff quickly swoop in to
shuffle him along during a quickie
escape the basement trip to pennsylvania
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
uh barracks
i think that was terrifying
what kind of country we're going to be
four more years of george uh
georgia he uh is going to find ourselves
in a position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
56 of americans said that they were
better off today
than they were four years ago would have
been under the obama binding
administration
so why should people who feel that they
are better off today
under the trump administration vote for
you well if they think that they
probably shouldn't
they think 54 american people are better
off economically today than they were
in our administration well their memory
is not very good quite frankly
a few moments later i'm running as a
proud democrat
for the senate
so vote boom visit iowa.com
ohio got in trouble when we're running
against the senator who was a mormon
the governor okay well their memory is
not very good quite frankly
[Applause]
it saves a lot of words in fact i can go
home now goodbye everybody
thank you thank you
only bring those very expensive boards
to a very special group of people
it's quite costly but it does save a lot
of talk doesn't it
joe biden has surrendered his party to
the rage-filled socialists and marxists
and
left-wing extremists the democrats know
that biden is just a vessel
to implement their socialist takeover
and that's what they're trying to do we
can't let that happen
that's why his running mate is the
number one most liberal member
of the u.s senate a sponsor of insane
this insane
a green new deal 100 trillion dollars
100 if we made if we had the greatest
hundred years
in history we couldn't pay a hundred
trillion dollars
this was made up by aoc plus three who i
don't know if she's ever even studied
the environment has you ever taken a
course on the environment i doubt it
biden and his party have spent the
entire year
inciting violence and hatred against our
police our great police
last night the city of philadelphia was
ransacked
by violent mobs of biden supporters for
a second night in a row
we could have stopped that that one we
could have stopped in 12 minutes
stores were looted nearly a dozen people
were shot
and dozens of officers were injured
would have been so easy
we're waiting for a call we'll send in
the federal government have to get a
call
we'll send in the federal government
we'll solve that problem so quickly
in seattle they took over a big part of
the city we said finally we have to go
in we didn't
have the permit we were doing it anyway
we let them know we're going in
as soon as we let them go we're going in
tomorrow morning we told them
as soon as we did that they held up
their hands and they said we're going
home
in minneapolis we went in a week and a
half later and i give the governor some
credit he said let's go
but it should have been a week earlier a
week and a half earlier
and they formed a line and it ended in
25 minutes it was all over minneapolis
that's why we're going to win the great
state of
minnesota we're going to win minnesota
because of that
for two reasons we're going to win
because of that and ilan
omar we're going to win because of her
too
how the hell does she get elected she
does not like
our country i can tell you biden and
harris
stand with the rioters and the vandals i
stand with the heroes
of law enforcement
and i think i've been endorsed by almost
every major police group in the united
states
and during the debate i asked him i said
joe who endorsed you any of the law
enforcement groups
he couldn't name one couldn't name one
then i said joe say the words
law enforcement say the words law
and order he wouldn't do it he wouldn't
do it number one he couldn't remember
the two words in conjunction
but more importantly he didn't want to
lose the radical left because if he says
those words
he loses the radical left this election
day you must stop
the anti-american radical say i mean
these are
radicals from delivering the far left
and thundering defeat you have to
deliver them
a defeat like they haven't seen before
not just a little one we don't want to
win this close
joe biden is a corrupt politician last
night we learned that joe
was intimately involved in the biden
family's corrupt business deals with
china jobs to china by the thousands
if biden wins china wins when we win you
win
arizona wins and america wins
you know that as big as that story was
last night
not one mention on social media
not one mention in big tech not one
mentioned in any of the major outlets
not one mention on any of the networks
only fox had it fox had it
tucker did a good job sean did a good
job
laura did a good job
not one mention so it's not freedom of
the press it's you know what we have
suppression of the president but this is
not
this is no longer freedom of the press
this is suppression
of the press and we have some very
powerful people right here
we cannot let this go on it's depression
it's unthinkable what's going on and yet
they'll write the littlest thing if
somebody
else does anything or doesn't have to do
it they make up fake stories
we're thrilled to be joined by somebody
that's done a great job
and been your great governor doug ducey
[Applause]
done a great job thank you doug
great job a woman who's running
for the senate currently a senator
respected by everybody
her opponent wants to terminate your
second
amendment martha mcsally martha
great great martha
martha come up just fast fast
fast come on quick you got one minute
one minute martha's saying
they don't want to hear this mother come
on let's go quick quick quick quick
come on let's go all right i'm coming
thank you president trump arizona we are
ground zero to save the country we have
six days in just a few hours president
trump and the country are counting on us
to send him back to the white house
for four more years everything is on the
line and my race is about the senate
majority
everything i wore the uniform for and
all you veterans did is on the line
everything is on the line we've got to
bring it home arizona
in my race will decide the direction of
the country the radical left can take
over in the senate
so if you want someone who's going to be
joe biden and chuck schumer's 51st vote
to take away our freedoms and our second
amendment rights and all the things the
president talk about
then you got a guy named mark kelly but
if you want a fighter
if you want to continue to have a
fighter who is proud to work with
president trump
for the great american comeback and
strong military and secure our borders
and your second amendment rights
then i'm your girl arizona i'm your girl
vote trump mcsally let's save the
country god bless you sir
thank you thank you thank you
very important and you know you can
think of a lot of things but think about
your second amendment his sole function
is to terminate your second amendment
and all of them that's what they want to
do and they're at lockstep
a friend of mine a great senator
somebody that has extraordinary common
sense
that's one of the reasons he's a
successful man at what he does
senator rand paul
[Applause]
come on up rant look at him
look at this guy come on up come on
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you here's to immunity
to immune people
i've got a message for independents
and libertarians my message is this
if you hate war like i hate war
if you want america to be supporting
america
not spending our money overseas and
wasting lives overseas in
unwinnable endless wars you need to
support the president who said this in
his
state of the union he said great nations
don't fight perpetual wars
thank you that's right
i have a message for african americans
across our country
biden and clinton failed you
the biden clinton crime bill locked up a
generation
unfairly locked up a generation of young
black men
joe biden said lock them up they're
super predators throw away the key
joe biden is responsible for decimating
our black community
when mike lee and i went to talk to the
president about the first step
act my wife was involved we talked about
how unfair it is
look at all the families out there can
anybody say your family's immune from
the scourge of drugs
that you haven't had a kid or a cousin
or a nephew or somebody that got hooked
on drugs
this president and i tried with
president obama and we got nowhere
but this president passed the first step
act
that let these people that were serving
30 years in jail
for non-violent crimes he set their
freedom
[Music]
and i have a message for those of you
who are sick and tired
of both republican and democrat
presidents
sending your money overseas to countries
that hate us
president trump says and i say not
one penny more for these countries that
hate us
thank you thank you rant you want a good
gun
great job brent thank you very much we
have another great senator
from the state of utah and he is
uh he's a smart one he's a good one he's
a respected one
mike lee come on up
come on
miss guerilla atlantis
[Music]
be
[Applause]
to my catholic friends think about a
couple of things as you approach the
ballot and your friends do
think about amy pony baron and think
about the little sisters of the poor
to my protestant and evangelical prince
we have to remember this by the grace
of our lord and savior jesus christ that
we've had four years of prosperity and
peace
to my mormon friends my latter-day saint
friends
thank you as captain alumni he takes
that power to
but to pull it down he seeks not the
praise of the world or the fake news
but he seeks the well-being and peace of
the american people
[Applause]
are you ready to stand with me and
millions and millions of others who want
four more years
[Applause]
thank you mike wow
good job
thank you very much rand and mike what a
job thank you that's why they're
successful
senators and respected by everybody
thank you
we have another great friend i think
he's going to be
replacing nancy pelosi soon i really
believe
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
come up kevin where's kevin
come up he's going to replace crazy
nancy
he's an incredible guy my friend
[Music]
thank you sir all right we got one
mission
we're going to elect the man who kept
more promises
than he ever made
[Applause]
we elect them we're going to have a
house
that defends them it stands for america
and when that day comes i want you all
to come to the swearing-in
[Applause]
it'll be before we swearing the
president again
but the reason why i want you to come i
want you to watch
nancy pelosi hand me that gavel
and i promise you this
i won't bang her with it but i'll bang
the end to the socialism
and yes to america
it's all up to you if you ask me the one
state that determines our future
it's arizona
i will promise you this i've never seen
a man work harder
i've never seen a man fight harder
and he's never asked anything but to
make america first thank you and god
bless
you wow thank you
kevin mccarthy thank you kevin
beautiful thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah right
so two people that have fought hard love
your state
they're tough they're brilliant and they
are warriors
andy biggs and debbie lesko where are
you
look at you
[Applause]
thanks andy thanks debbie
a friend of mine a lot of people say one
of the most powerful
men in europe nigel farage
[Applause]
come on up nigel
he's a very non-controversial person too
right
that's what we're like come on nigel
he's very shy
oh i'm non-controversial and shy
compared to you i gotta say
four years ago i was honored to come to
america
to bring the brexit message the message
that you can beat the establishment
and that is what donald trump did
he beat the pollsters he beat the media
he beat all the predictions
and here's the worst bit they've never
forgiven him for it they've never
ever forgiven him they have spent four
years
trying to delegitimize him four years
of the russia hoax four years of a false
impeachment
most human beings under that barrage
would have given up this is
the single most resilient and bravest
person
i have ever met in my
life
and when you vote next week you are not
just voting
for who the president of the united
states of america is
vital though that question may be you
are voting
for the leader of the free world
[Applause]
[Music]
you are voting you are voting for the
only
current leader in the free world who has
got the guts
to stand up and fight for the nation
state
to fight for patriotism to fight
against globalism you'll be voting for
the only leader in the western world
with the real courage to stand up to the
chinese communist party
you'll be voting
you'll be voting for decency
plain speaking and a man who in four
years
hasn't just cut your taxes hasn't just
improved the economy but a man who right
now
is bringing israel together with arab
nations
in a way that nobody ever believed was
possible
and that's what he's done and i wish you
godspeed
i really do thank you
[Applause]
thank you nigel that's something well
thank you i'm glad i called him up
i'm glad i could thank you very much
nigel that's something
he's responsible for a lot of things
that have happened over in europe
very positive things too thank you very
much
a friend of mine who is a brilliant
brilliant gentleman he loves fights he
just loves fighting
he's somebody that's made a lot of money
with fighting a lot of people say oh
let's not fight but he disagrees
he owns that he's the head of the ufc
you know what that is
dana white the great day in her wife
[Applause]
thank you dana thank you guys something
i'll tell you what a job he's done
state treasurer kimberly yee kimberly
kimberly where is kimberly thank you
kimberly good job you do it
[Music]
how are the finances okay you're doing
well
good maricopa county supervisor
clint hickman
[Applause]
thank you cliff good job flit
gop chair she's tough she's smart and
she's with us and she's always been with
us
she works hard kelly ward
he's great he's great
so thank you all very much i was very
interesting i didn't think you'd have
anyone speak but it was one after
another i'm glad they did it right that
was great
we don't usually do that usually it gets
a little boring when people speak
this group was a hell of a group thank
you all thank you all very much
together we built the greatest economy
in history and now we're doing it again
we increase middle class family income
over
five thousand dollars more than five
times the gains
under the last administration
after the virus arrived we passed three
trillion dollars in economic relief
and saved over 50 million jobs many in
your state many
many in your state we've experienced the
smallest contraction
and the fastest recovery economically
by far of any major nation in the world
that's a big thing
and our numbers are going to be coming
out very shortly very soon gdp
and the fed in atlanta just made a
prediction
they said 35 now i'll take 25 right now
35 would be many times larger than the
largest number we've ever had gdp the
all-important gdp
35 is what they predict and let's see
what happens and it'll be three days
before the election
so i'll make a deal if the number's a
bad number you don't have to vote for me
okay but i think it's going to be
incredible if you look at housing starts
if you look at automobile and
all the productivity that we've had if
you looked at hiring 11.4 million people
over a short period of time
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure border in u.s history
and we built over 400 miles of new wall
including 200 miles right here
in the state of arizona 200 now
it goes down very deep and it goes up
very high you know there are two reasons
it goes down deep
one is to hold it up and the other is
for tunnels
you never had it so good and your
numbers are fantastic
joe biden has pledged to open borders he
even said maybe we'll rip down the wall
i don't think that's going to happen
he wants open borders if you don't have
borders you don't have a country
his plan would completely eliminate our
borders by implementing nationwide catch
and release you catch him
a killer a rapist whoever it is and you
release him into our country
and then in the debate he said oh but
they come back for trial no they don't
joke they don't come back
you don't see him again this would
trigger a tsunami of illegal immigration
from every corner all over the world
he's also pledged to and you know what
he wants to do give free health care
and mass amnesty for all illegal border
crosses
bankrupting your medicare and your
social security systems
i don't think so and you know we all
have a heart we want to take care of
people but
everybody all over the world would pour
into our country
we wouldn't be able to do it under
biden's plan
you'll have no borders no health care no
middle class you'll have no country
frankly
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military including nearly one
billion dollars
to build the world's most advanced
guided missiles
guess where we're building them right
here in arizona
we also passed va choice and va
accountability things said that
you'll never get them done sir you'll
never get it done we got them both done
accountability
where we can fire bad people that work
at the va that don't love our vets
we take care of our vets and now they
don't have to wait for two weeks three
weeks five weeks seven
weeks now they go and if they can't get
good service we have great doctors in
the va but if you can't get the service
you go to a local doctor local hospital
we take care of the bill
we have a 91 approval rating now the
highest ever by far
with our best
[Applause]
we took 100 of the isis caliphate and we
killed the leader of isis al baghdadi
[Applause]
we took out the world's top terrorists
salamani is dead
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous
iran nuclear deal 150 billion dollars
for nothing
for nothing recognized the capital of
israel and opened the american embassy
in jerusalem
and even got it built and even got it
built right i even got it built
got it built for supposed to cost two
billion dollars we did it for five
hundred thousand a slight
cost underrun that was called the cost
under and you don't see that in
government too much
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
they've been working on that for 52
years i got it done in about two hours
every president promised these things
but they never got them done
a lot of pressure on people when you
have that jerusalem
golan heights a lot of pressure but we
got them done and instead of
never ending wars we are forging peace
in the middle east
we are forging peace
and i've said this and i've said it a
lot but i mean it with every breath
i've done more in 47 months than sleepy
joe biden has done
in 47 years
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities great jobs
and the american dream you know abraham
lincoln was a great republican just
remember that
i can be more presidential than any
president other than possibly abraham
lincoln when he's wearing the hat
that's a tough one now he was a great
republican
over the next four years in conclusion
we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all that's already started
we will make our medical supplies right
here in the united states right here in
arizona
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will defend religious liberty free
speech
the right to life and the right to keep
and bear arms second amendment
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength that's what we have
and the 2.5 trillion all made in the usa
we have the finest missiles and rockets
and tanks and submarines and
jets the f-35 stealth you can't see it
sir you can't see it that makes it good
i said i think that makes it good what
do i know
but i know if you're the opponent and
you can't see the jet you know what
you got a little advantage there
now we have the best in the world and
our nuclear arsenal has been refurbished
and restocked and hoped to god we never
have to use it
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency already completed
goes into effect bigger than health care
you watch
on january 1st lower drug prices even
more
first year in 52 years the drug prices
prescription
went down but i instituted what's called
the favorite nations laws we pay the
most in the world
we're now going to be tied for the
lowest price in the world
we will protect your social security and
your medicare
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
[Music]
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation
to land an astronaut on mars
and nasa nasa is now
again the preeminent space station
there's nothing like what we have
what a job they've all done including
our great vice president
mike pence we will stop the radical
indoctrination of our students
and restore patriotic education
to our schools
[Applause]
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american plan
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto in god we
trust
[Applause]
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america and standing up
for the people of arizona
[Applause]
from tombstone to tucson right tucson
does anybody come from tucson my friend
comes from tusa
from nasa to yuma from prescott
to right here in goodyear goodyear
we inherit the legacy of red-blooded
american patriots
who poured out their hearts sweat and
soul
to secure our liberty and defend our
freedom
this great state was settled by some of
the toughest men
and strongest women ever to walk
the face of this great wonderful
beautiful planet
arizona's where wyatt earp and doc
holliday became
american legends it's where the great
american west became
the american dream and arizona is the
state where generations of pioneers and
prospectors
minors and ranchers cowboys and cattle
hands
marshals and lawmen tame the frontier
braved the blazing sun like i'm doing
right now
and showed the entire world how the west
was won
they helped make america into the
greatest nation in the history of the
world
and the best is yet to come
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of arizona go out and vote
go out and vote we have made
america powerful again we have made
america
wealthy again we have made america
strong again
we have made america proud again
proud we have made
america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you very much thank
you arizona go out
and vote thank you
[Music]
cause
you can stay there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
to the ymca i'm sure
[Applause]
they
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
someone came up to me and said come on
it's fun
[Music]
you can hang out with
[Music]
[Music]
pick yourself up
[Music]
young man
what you